It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for our 157th episode!
BAU BAU!
That's a lot of mornings now.
Have any more too.
But for Ruffians joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
So, please,
Please, Moco-chan, please!
Tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Speedy intro today!
We just wanna get you the info, Ruffians!
We're here to wake you up and get you up for the day.
Right!
We're just gonna pull those sheets off.
Time to get up and kick you up the morning!
Just the facts, yes.
Important info, yes.
Yeah, it's supposed to be short format after all, huh?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I am finally good!
Well, let's keep it that way, huh?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Well, it's Wednesday, Moco-chan.
What do you have for the wolfies today?
Another Pero?
Why, no.
Can we just not?
Let's see!
Where do we see Pero this time?
De-den!
Wow!
I don't know what to say.
You know, usually, safety reasons, Ruffians, you know.
Self-defense, you know.
Poke the balloon, those kind of things, but... Well, you know, Pero?
Pero looks really chill here, right?
Comfy, huh?
Right.
I don't know.
Kind of makes me want to go out and enjoy the summer, too.
Right.
What about you, Ruffians?
Ruffians, are you already in summer mode now?
Yeah?
Yeah.
You want to swim?
Doggy paddle, right?
Yes, doggy paddle.
That's his pool now.
Well, you know.
I'll deny that.
He has his glasses on.
He looks kind of sleepy.
Maybe you could just kind of go in there and splash quite quietly to yourself in the corner.
You're still in spring mode.
You miss winter?
Well, winter's just right around the corner once you get to the summer time and the fall time, right?
You know.
He's alright.
I'm still awake somewhere.
I haven't seen Pero swim before.
Ruffians, do you think Pero can swim?
Push him under the water then.
What do you think?
I feel like his little wings could go bop bop bop bop, but I don't think... He's pure muscle, right?
I think if he was to swim on his side, he'd kind of be like a shark.
Pure muscle.
Sink.
Right.
Float.
I think you sound right, Moco-chan.
Well, we haven't tried, but... Muscles!
You don't have to float!
Pero looks so comfy here.
We're not gonna do anything.
We'll just leave him be.
You know, I just... I feel bad looking at this.
I know it'll happen.
Something will happen.
I just know it.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, do you feel like you're looking forward to the summertime a bit more now?
Well...
We're starting to get all the heat, but... Maybe I'll still be fine, huh?
Excited!
Yeah!
How you know?
All Hawaii shaved ice!
We'll party together the whole year!
Those things sound fun too!
Let's look forward to the summer!
Yeah, and the cicadas.
BAU BAU!
Thanks for Pero, you know, teaching us the important things.
We'll enjoy summer.
Yeah, you know.
This is not all hot and sweat.
Let's hope Pero brings back holo-summer.
BAU BAU!
Speaking of the summer.
Yeah, and speaking of things that you know we've all been waiting for for a long time!
We've been looking forward to!
So so much!
Early on the hololive official English channel!
Bae-senpai, IRyS-senpai, and Biboo!
They had a 3D livestream with some breaking news!
I heard things got pretty silly, but more importantly, it's finally here!
hololive English's second concert, "Breaking Dimensions," is now on Blu-ray!
Yes!
Finally!
Exciting!
Finally, finally!
Another second concert!
It happened in New York City last year!
Can you believe it?
Now it's so long ago, but it doesn't feel like it.
It doesn't feel like it, but... But on this Blu-ray disc, you can find both Day 1 and Day 2 of live performances from all of hololive English.
Very, very important snapshot back into 2024.
I can't believe it's been so long.
What took so long?
It's not a given!
You know!
Please, please, please, please, please, please!
We've been asking too!
Blue Ray, Blue Ray, Blue Ray, Blue Ray!
Please!
Yeah.
They didn't, they didn't get us a DVD version.
VHS!
I wanted a DVD version!
Imagine you made a VHS version and you brought it back in the past.
You know, for FUWAMOCO, it's really really important because it was my first time performing on the big stage together with our senpai.
In New York too!
Yeah, it really meant a lot to us, you know.
Performing Purupururiri with Biboo and Abe-senpai.
You know, seeing Bono-senpai stay with me in the middle of the night.
Mumei-senpai's a new star!
You know, being able to see all of us singing Reunion together.
There's always that one part where I get so teary.
Right.
I don't know, Reunion was always a really good song, but after that performance.
The choreography is just so good.
You know, Reunion's a really special song.
They're all performances that we'll never ever forget, but with this blu-ray disc, now we can relive it as many times as we want.
But, Ruffians, you can get it on the official hololive shop, but it's available on pre-order until June 5th, about one month.
So, we really recommend pre-ordering yours now before you forget!
We will!
We are going to, yes!
Because FUWAMOCO we have the experience of getting to order Connect the World's Blu-ray of our first concert.
Who here has Connect the World's Blu-ray?
Can you give it to us?
Because we didn't get it and now we regret it forever.
It's impossible to get.
It's impossible.
We have looked everywhere.
We have asked for a long time.
So many stuff is on.
No.
Excuse me.
Do you have any copies of Connect the World lying around?
I mean, you know.
Nope.
Can't give you one if they don't have one.
Yeah.
So Ruffians, we're waiting for a reprint of it, just like you.
We are the biggest supporter.
Wanna do a Inao Connect World rerun?
We'll ask again.
So Ruffians, just make sure you don't repeat what we did.
Because it's very special.
If you feel like you want to archive this special, special moment for hololive English, then now's the time, you know?
Or you could ask Shiori.
I don't know if that's gonna work out in the Ruffians' favors, but... You know, also Rikki dimensions, it was our first time performing our original song, Blame to be Balla, on stage, so... Hopefully you can see a bit of improvement, some changes and stuff.
But we hope that you'll decide to get it, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Are you ready to start the day with a couple extra items?
Looks like it's gonna be lots of fun!
Sounds like there's some anticipation there.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
We have some more news!
Talking about New York!
New York!
Kinda close to New York.
Is it close to New York?
I think it's close to New York.
Ruffians let us know if it's close to New York!
FUWAMOCO unofficial world tour continues!
New year, new unofficial world tour!
New York is next in the polls!
We're going to Boston!
Boston!
BALLISTIN!
Yes!
We're going to be a ballistin for the whole week!
Super Kyle can finally ballistin!
Yeah!
Together we'll be there at the base!
Fun!
We're really really excited, you know, and a little bit nervous because this time we'll be dancing around and singing and dancing!
Moco-chan, what do you think of the set list?
I think you'll be excited, but it's a bit different, I feel.
Maybe it was a bit different.
Is it still a bit different?
I don't know.
We thought really, really hard about it.
Really, really hard.
We have, you know, some classic hololive songs.
Classic anime songs.
Classic songs overall.
Right.
So you'll definitely want to be there.
I think it's better than we haven't sung before.
We haven't, we haven't.
No, no.
It's a good thing it's kind of an embarrassing song.
But we have a very fun setlist prepared.
So Ruffians, we hope that you'll jam out together with us!
And most importantly and all, don't forget your pen lights and your big bobo's and probably the blanket too.
Okay!
I'm excited but nervous, excited but nervous.
Always the case, Moco-chan.
But we'll do our best there, so we hope to see you on May 24th in Boston!
BAU BAU!
Anime Baustan.
What would Bae-senpai be doing?
Oh right.
Probably something different from us.
We did suggest some songs.
But then, I think... Oh no, we didn't steal them.
It's okay.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Bae-sen!
Baustan!
It both works.
Both works.
It's good.
Anime Baustan.
Yeah!
But you know, not just Anime Boston.
There's gonna be another very exciting hololive related event coming up shortly.
Yeah, and we thought we would share it!
On... what month is it?
ME!
I'm being so reticed!
In Tokyo, there's gonna be a hololive fan event called "Holokle" happening!
Holokle!
It's made by a whole bunch of hololisters.
It's a doujin event.
I don't know if it's a fan doujin.
Fan event!
Fan event, yeah.
Run by other hololive fans.
And this is actually the ninth time.
Right.
And look at FUWAMOCO!
We're out there!
We're out there on the
Drawn by Ayamy-sensei!
So cute!
Thank you Ayamy-sensei!
We were excited to see on Twitter, you know?
So cute!
But you know, FUWAMOCO, we really really like you know, doujin works, fan works.
Yeah, but in case you're not really certain, these sort of events, there's a bunch of fun things going on.
But mainly there's a lot of unofficial fan works.
Books!
You know, doujin shi, any sort of fan works.
From a lot of different circles, all fans, you know.
And this time also including Icomochi-mama!
Icomochi-mama will be there too!
And Ayamy-sensei!
We're just so excited and really really happy to see so many circles, hololive.
We always really want to support doujinshi events, you know, fan events and everything like that.
We hope that we can get our paws on everyone's legs somehow.
Thank you!
I know us.
In the past, we talked about taking, you know, a photo of our treasures.
I don't know if it's gonna fit in a photo anymore, Ruffians.
We did attempt it.
We did attempt it, we did.
But... It would've taken a... We were struggling!
Probably twice over.
Multiple photos then!
That's a lot of photos.
Yeah, I think, yeah.
Is it that much?
Lots of treasures.
Lots of treasures!
Thank you for your time!
Thank you so much to all the sequels.
You're creating wonderful works.
You know there's also Komike as well.
Komike is coming up in the summertime.
We'll be looking forward to that.
Please, please keep on creating.
Creating the things that you want to make with all your heart.
Yeah, we're always here to support you, okay?
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Mane-chan, ganbare!
Ya!
You know, Mane-chan's list keeps on getting bigger and bigger by the end.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
Do you remember?
The other day?
On Monday.
Monday FUWAMOCO Morning.
Kinda started off on a bit of a wrong paw.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Why?
I've never heard that.
Not the meatballs!
It wasn't the meatballs!
But Ruffians, I guess they continue, they continue.
You know, that same day, we went to the grocery store and got some groceries.
More natto!
And our total, it came up to 4,444 yen.
What do you do?
That's a very ominous number in Japan.
What do you do when that happens?
Because boy can also read like that.
What are you supposed to do?
Are you supposed to do something because she'd be like, excuse me, um, I can't, I can't pay this, uh, can I, can I just grab a candy or something?
But it was already, it was already all done and they're like, please go pay and... Yeah.
You don't pay!
At that point you just don't pay!
Call Calli-senpai!
Demand an explanation!
I think I will!
I think that sounds like a good idea!
I think that!
You don't!
Because what's even worse is nothing particularly bad happened that day.
But when does it end?
When's it gonna happen, you know?
I don't know what to do, Ruffians!
Is this something that, you know, pon-de-rings can solve?
Headpods can fix it?
What?
What do we do now?
But it's funny though because in the middle of Gears Solid 3 we have our save data, right?
2025 05 05 00 11 11 10 Yeah.
I don't know.
If it had been 4 4 4 4, would we have been unhappy?
I would be scared.
But we keep the save, right?
Haunted save.
Wearing swimsuits is not the answer to everything, Ruffians!
Swimsuits is not the answer to everything, okay?
BAU BAU.
Maybe we'll call the Calli-senpai.
Shiawase no.
Shie.
I won't have pants.
I'm pondering.
Okay, Ruffians.
I'm gonna ask Calli-senpai.
She'll maybe show her advice.
I don't think we're particularly suspicious.
Superstitious.
We're a little bit suspicious.
Hopefully nothing bad happens.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we've already talked about the new exciting blog breaking the legends.
But there's also exciting stuff in case you missed it.
Yeah, as you might know, right now we're celebrating our 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
We are 1 million!
On FUWAMOCO, we have a very deluxe set of merchandise that we carefully produced ourselves.
FUWAMOCO!
With these old paws.
And here we take a look at our Moco-chan.
Well you can see here, Icomochi-mama and Mama!
She's done the illustration for it there!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Icomochi-mama!
I'm so so lucky!
Well first we have a Dreams Come True Acrylic Diorama Stand!
Yes!
And see you know, this is the first!
The first!
The first Diorama Stand Acrylic Stand of FUWAMOCO us together!
The first one!
The first one ever!
And Ruffians!
Today you are with us to make us petal too!
You know, so it's extra special and must have in the collection!
And you already have a sponsor for it!
BAU BAU!
We're really looking forward to it too, you know.
We wanted to be a very special acrylic diorama.
You know.
Why is it taking so long to get here, you know?
We've all been waiting.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you remember on the day we debuted, I pledged.
I pledged.
I pledged of loyalty.
You haven't forgotten, right?
To protect you smile, Ruffians.
From us to you.
And here.
You can get it.
You can have that.
I pledged forever and ever.
And you know that way, maybe on days that are a little rough, you can take a look at it and be like,
FUWAMOCO.
I've heard some rumors that if you order four, then sometimes you get all four.
It's a rumor!
I haven't tested it.
It's not tested.
It's quite a rumor.
So, you know... Gotcha.
Gotcha.
But I mean, if you get all four Mococos, is that a problem?
That's not a problem, right?
Ruffians, that's not a problem, right?
If you pull all four Mococos, are you gonna be like... AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Really?
Of course not!
Of course not.
Yeah.
You won't be like Megafore the same.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Stylish when you wanna be, you know.
Really show all your oishii kaito passion!
We hope you'll get your paws on it, Ruffians.
We put a lot of thought into it.
Fuyu komi ni motte ikou.
It's perfect for komiken.
Fuyu komi ni pittari da ne.
BAU BAU!
And last but not least, digital!
We have a voice pack of FUWAMOCO daily talks on system sounds.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
How about a month?
Maybe a little less than that to be able to pre-order it.
Please get your paws on it!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Let's take you on a trip!
You know, lots of exciting things happening, but I really like checking out the Doggie of the Day.
Is that what you want to do?
The Doggie of the Day?
Right?
The Doggie of the Day always makes the day happier, right?
Yes!
Doggy the day, Moco-chan!
It's Wednesday.
It's Wednesday, yeah?
It's FUWAMOCO Morning.
Wednesday.
Pup Talk?
What's this Pup Talk?
Ruffians are talking about- Where's the Pup Talk?!
!
Hi.
Moco-chan, maybe you have some encouraging words for us.
Hi!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
You know, in the past, how we've had wake-up style Pup Talks, right?
Right!
Well, this year,
This here is a sleepy style!
Sleepy sleep style pup talk!
Are you sleepy?
Do you think that... maybe... today was Monday?
Are you a bit out of it?
Do you need... an extra five minutes?
No?
Well...
You've been doing your best, but sometimes, you know, it's just time to give yourself a little bit more leniency, a little bit more kindness.
So, we're gonna take a small nap together!
That was a really loud announcement.
Okay.
Got it.
I'm getting comfy.
Very, very, very comfy.
You're already sleepy beforehand, so let's cover it.
No more getting sleepy.
Now, close your eyes.
Very, very slowly.
Slowly.
And deep breaths.
In and out.
Nipi.
Wawa.
Moco-chan.
Nipi.
Moco-chan!
Ha.
Well, how was it?
How was the nap?
BAU BAU!
Do you feel a little bit more rested and relaxed?
Yeah?
Well, let's all do our best in the last bit of the week until Friday, okay?
Rested, yes, good.
You can do it!
Ganbatte de!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
The Doggie of the Day!
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Biscuit!
Biscuit!
Wow, what a rink.
What?
Look at the rink.
Super suave.
Can I like this?
Does it look good?
Let's see Moco-chan.
Oh!
I would say it's biscuit-esque.
Oh, that was good.
BAU BAU!
But, but, but, look!
Look at Biscuit's mum on arm!
It's so cute!
Cute!
It's cute!
The longer I look at it, the cuter it gets.
Moco-chan, you're so tired.
Oh, wink biscuit.
Wink!
I don't think you can.
How does biscuit bow bow, Moco-chan?
I think it'll be sort of like... You know biscuit's pretty soft, maybe like... BOW BOW.
BOW BOW.
It's Biscuit!
Yeah!
Why is he winking?
I don't know if Hey Lady is that polite, Moco-chan.
That was him being slob!
Hey Lady.
BAU BAU!
It's Biscuit!
Yes!
Okay, Moco-chan.
Actually, Biscuit is a much much more well-trained gentleman.
Hi!
But, you know Abyssgard, you can tell he have a biscuit is a super cute toasted potato baby boy.
Momo knows, Momo knows.
Right.
You know, and the fact that he's become your shadow is true prove just how much he loves you.
You have a biscuit shadow.
Delicious.
But you know, also, it's pretty obvious, but the cuddles, the kisses, the winks, too.
Those are all proof, too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for making this FUWAMOCO channel, Biscuit!
Thank you.
Looks like egg, yeah!
It's not egg, it's biscuit.
Biscuit.
BAU BAU!
We're just gonna go on a walk right now.
Moco-chan.
Walk, okay!
FUWAMOCO!
Show us.
Where did you go on a walk?
We have de-den!
What is this?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It's beautiful!
We're really glad that you got out.
A bit of a bike ride adventure despite the rain.
You know sometimes the rain makes it even more fun, right?
I bet you were a soggy doggy after all.
Let's hope it was a soggy doggy.
But as long as you have lots of fun, and it seems like you saw lots of different things and had a good time, so... That's important.
Cool car too.
Good memories!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing your walk with us!
Thank you!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
I'm curious what you both consider to be the ideal heroine in the VN's Vision novels you play.
Do you save them for the last, or do you gun for them first?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
You know, if there's one, your favorite girl, then I feel like saving her for last is best because you want her to be the true end, right?
That's true.
You want to end with the true end in your heart.
Well, this is not the true end, though.
She's just a side hero here.
You didn't even have an end, you cry.
No, don't cry.
Yeah, or you write a bad review.
No, no, but I think, you know, the most fun way is just to kind of go in blind, you know, be like, OK, I kind of like her.
Maybe I'm going to try and aim for her ruler.
But if it doesn't happen, well, we'll see where we go, you know?
That's the most fun way to be able to just enjoy a visual novel.
Visual novels are life.
I'll see where this goes.
That's the number one way I think to go on the adventure.
And if it ends up well, good.
And if it doesn't end up well, well that's maybe part of the story.
We should all go say FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Blind playthroughs are the best.
You keep on dying and then that's better.
A lot of people said that recently.
BAU BAU.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We're always looking for more submissions from you because you know FUWAMOCO Morning, we're your hosts.
FUWAMOCO, we're your hosts.
But Ruffians, you're a very important part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
So we're always waiting for your Pero sightings.
Doggy of the days, your walks, I wanna see where you're going.
And your questions too!
So please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And our next team!
Well, we have a schedule.
Because our next stream is an Advent collab.
We're going to be playing Jackbox Games on Biboo's channel on Thursday at 6pm PT.
It's been quite a while, way too long since our last Advent collab.
Which is good because Jackbox Games can get kind of crazy sometimes, right?
It is good.
Be extra crazy.
Not too sure what's gonna happen, yeah.
We always love Advent Co-op.
I know.
It's a Jackbox game, so we'll see what happens.
We hope that you join us in all of Advent Day.
And otherwise, we have... On the weekend on Saturday at 6pm, we're gonna be starting Fatal Frame on PS2.
6pm or 5pm?
I can't remember.
5pm.
5pm!
An hour earlier.
Important.
And you know the PS2 I think is doing pretty well.
I wasn't complaining too much earlier with Metal Gear Solid 3.
Especially when we forgot to turn it off after we finished playing.
Yeah, it's off now.
But you know Fatal Frame is a classic, a legendary horror game.
And we're kinda not the best at horror games.
Right, Ruffians?
Are we getting better?
I don't like mirrors.
I don't like windows.
I don't like screens.
I don't like cameras.
You know FUWAMOCO is the perfect game if you don't like cameras, right?
We'll find out how it goes, but please be there to hold our paws while viewing!
And in between we have a 2AM PT on Sunday.
We're gonna be over on Ruri-senpai's channel for an Animal Tower Battle Tournament.
It's a very simple but complicated game where we stack animals on top of each other to make a tower.
Animal.
I'm pretty good at it.
I don't think you need to understand much to enjoy.
Yes.
Sometimes it can be a very cruel game.
We'll see what happens.
Yes.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
We're looking forward to a really fun weekend all together!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU BLU-RAY!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Nea!
BAU BAU!
Great Charlie!
Ikiasura!
BAU BAU!
Fly Foxy!
Zane!
BAU BAU!
Doomin!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!